mistake we've made is that we think the
only currency of business is money
it's not there are two currencies will
and resources in that order the will of
the people
and the resources available to continue
to help advance the cause you have to
have money you have to be profitable
it's like having the perfect car you
might have the perfect culture you might
have the most amazing car but if you
have no fuel
to make that car go uh
then then you never achieve anything
money is a finite resource whether
you're getting it from a customer or
from an investor
um whether you're getting it from a
stock market or uh
from other sort for uh forms of
investment
it is finite it can run out and it can
stop coming in that's why you have to
produce good
good product and good marketing to help
uh
keep the resource coming in it's like
drilling you have to keep drilling or
or putting up solar panels if you want
more energy
you got to have a resource producer
but will of the people is unlimited and
and that's where good leadership comes
in
and one of the things that's been so
interesting especially during covert
times
which is i think people like money money
doesn't just sit like this and it
doesn't just go like this like it's not
just a
hockey stick you know money goes like
this it can be affected by weather by
politics by
marketing you maybe have a good product
or a brad product and it goes like this
the goal is to keep the trend up right
um
or at least stable but the same thing is
with will you know people have good days
people have bad days
leaders show up badly and leaders show
up well it's like this but overall
you want to keep the trend of of the
will
um in a positive direction which is
every leader and remember leader has
nothing to do with
rank anyone can be a leader at any level
that's the important thing here this is
not just the responsibility
of senior leadership senior leadership
has to go first to model the behavior
that's ideal
but everyone who's showing up to be the
leader they wish they had
actually helps keep that will up on high
and this is why it's so important for
senior leadership to take care
of the the people in their charge who
are then uh told to take care of the
people on their charge who then told to
take
people in in their charge it's like mom
and dad taking care of the older kids
and asking the older
kids to take care of the little kids
it's kind of like that and then what
ends up happening is you have a loving
trusting family
again good days bad days it all happens
you have ranges of emotion we are human
but that is the point of will and
resources that we have to invest in will
just like we take investment or invest
in
[Music]
money